so how do you feel about that impact
that you're making for people like me
who are kind of
geeky nerds to actually sit down be
introspective
about what they're doing is that a value
to you what
what is rewarding is to hear people
that the philosophies and the content
shared on valuetainment helped them
get clear on a decision they had to make
it's very very rewarding
what i what i don't do to myself
is i don't sit there and make myself
think that it's that big of a deal of
what i'm doing because it goes back to
the stoic stoic
of marcus irelias who would put a slave
behind him whispering in his ear you are
not as important as you think you are
because
sometimes i think when we uh allow too
much of the edification and the praise
and the flattery that comes your way you
are
almost stunned you know it stunts your
growth to the next level and i'm always
i'm curious about the unknown you know
because
i already know what today feels like i
want to know what this feels like what
is
what is the possibility of raising kids
who one day they're able to do stuff
their dad couldn't do and
you know they're inspired to take this
mindset to the next level
i'm always curious about the unknown so
in one way very rewarding
on the other side i also don't put a lot
of uh i don't
wake up and say oh my gosh i need more
of it yeah and that's simply because i'm
curious about the next level
there's a lot of psychology in this book
and what i like about it is you're just
like here's what you do when somebody
ticks you off
take responsibility state specifically
what you did channel your frustration
into getting better so it's a
self-improvement book
masquerading as a business book but what
do you say to people
um like some of the skeptics who who
like feel about gary vee
or somebody like that that they are
really just kind of promoting their own
book they're really like to use the
insurance or whatever like they're
selling their own stuff
and and they actually are depending on
people to fail
it seems like you are engaged with
people succeeding not failing like
weight watchers they only make business
because people like me
go back and recidivism is high how do
you
how do you like uh keep integrity in
such in such an environment
you know i read a quote a long time ago
by is
is it richard branson the guy from
virgin i think it's richard branson
he said teach your guys your employees
everything that you know so they can go
away
leave you and compete against you but
treat them so well that they don't want
to
okay i mean it's a fascinating message
to be given right where it's interesting
listen i'm gonna share everything
i do with you guys i select one of the
things i have a reputation for if you
work with me
i always like to do meetings and another
person sit next to me because i want you
to learn how i negotiate i want you to
learn
how to put out a fire i want you to know
and see
well that one time pat got heated but he
went from heated to this point and how
was he able to bring it down and why did
it get heated and
but he's done this seven different times
and it's always worked out well and what
happened there
how is it that two personalities get
heated and then they end up becoming
friends and do business together
for a long time and you know he realizes
what area he has to say that was my bad
will fix it and the other year puts the
pressure on the other person
because because it's an element of
shadowing and learning from somebody
else on what to do and what not to do
if you if you were not going to go to
college but you're going to create
bet david university what would you
offer what would you teach the students
there that they
would need to know and could uniquely
learn from you if i were to start a
university one day let's call it
david university my university would be
very very different here's how my
university would be if we're teaching
if we're teaching economics you would
have two professors
or maybe three professors you would have
a social media communist and a
capitalist
and you get to watch them debate
non-stop that's how i would teach
if you want to have a you know a course
you're taking on marriage and
relationship you would have somebody
that's single never got married you'd
have somebody that's divorced happily
divorced
and you got somebody that's happily
married they're each gonna sell you why
you
ought to consider getting married why
you ought to consider you know marriage
is tough to be
or i'm just happy staying single if i'm
teaching you negotiation skills you
would get the people that are
you know hostage negotiators you would
get people that went to prison and are
drug dealers
you get the people that worked in the
streets you get the people that worked
in the business world that did the
biggest deals when it comes down to
negotiation
you will learn that you learn human
nature you have people sitting down on
stage
and i would say can you read that
person's body language how do they feel
right now do they trust you do they not
trust you
what's that giving you what is this
giving you how do you read this person's
tale how do you read that person's tale
it would be a very different kind of a
human nature university be going to
and then of course we would have the
courses to teach but it wouldn't be
about oh i got a four-year degree from
bed david university
right it would be it would be more
closer to an academy
a military toughness mental emotional
toughness type of an academy when you
come out of there being the future
governor president ceos
you know disrupters of the world and
things that you gravitate towards like a
magnetic field
so it depends on what the position is
and what you're doing for example i'll
break it down for you if i'm dealing
with a sales
person uh or somebody is in sales that's
working 10.99
i look for somebody that played sports i
look for somebody that's got a chip i
look for somebody that uh
you know had a massive public
humiliation of a loss a breakup
i looked for somebody that had major
challenges that took place with them
uh i look for that if i'm dealing with
uh sales and so because
they have to be competitive you got to
be willing to do the work operations
and customer service i'm looking for
somebody that's
you know maybe a certain spiritual
foundation
faith but we're a little bit more easy
going to deal with customers and if i'm
dealing with somebody that's
uh finances and it's economics i almost
need somebody that's a little bit of a
loner
uh uh you know i need somebody that's
not doesn't talk too much that
maybe is not very personable maybe it's
a little bit private
uh doesn't uh want a lot of bragging
rights it all depends
on position and department but yes
everybody has a little bit of a cork
that helps
in that department
you